In summary, you really learned about correlation coefficients.
It's larger than 0.
If there's a positive relationship between x and y.
It's smaller than 0 if the relationship is negative.
It's equal to 0 if there is no relationship.
The magnitude of r goes to 1 as the relationship becomes increasingly linear
without any noise or any deviation from the line.
This is a powerful measure.
For any data set with multiple variables,
you can now tell how much variables relate to each other.
If someone, for example, shows you the salary of a person and the age of a person,
you can say they're really correlated, or you could say they're not correlated at all.
Whatever you say, with this--what I believe to be a very simple formula,
the formula right over here--you can now compute for any data set how much x and y relate.
That's called the correlation, and it's really an important lesson in statistics.
I use it all the time to inspect data to make a statement
how much two variables relate to each other in a linear way. Thank you.